hey everyone it's sarah register nurse
rn.com in this video i'm going to be
talking about the glasgow coma scale and
as always whenever you get done watching
this youtube video you can access the
free quiz that will test you on this
content so let's get started the glasgow
coma scale is used to assess a patient's
level of consciousness and level of
consciousness is how alert and
responsive a patient is to their
environment and the stimuli around them
so in order to be alert and responsive
to your environment with all of its
stimuli you have to have really good
brain functioning
therefore this tool is really helpful in
evaluating patients who've experienced
traumatic brain injuries or other
conditions where brain functioning and
consciousness is altered so we can use
this tool to calculate a specific score
so in practice you may hear someone say
their patient has a gcs of 7 or a gcs of
10 whenever they say this they are
referring to the glasgow coma scale that
is where those letters gcs come from now
when assessing the gcs you want to make
sure that you get a baseline score on
your patient you want to know where they
started at and then throughout your
shift make sure you are often
reassessing the gcs per your facilities
protocol because we want to be able to
look at their score and say okay they're
improving they're not really changing or
they're deteriorating because level of
consciousness tells us so much about our
patient any changes in level of
consciousness could be a warning sign
that something is going on with our
patient and we need to investigate it so
this tool assesses three responses by
the patient to a type of stimuli and
those three responses include eye
opening response
verbal response and motor response so to
help test the patient for their best
response in these areas you may have to
use some type of stimuli and this
stimuli can be as simple as a verbal
stimulus to the patient to a little bit
more of an involved one where you have
to touch the patient and deliver a
painful or pressure stimulus
now let me talk a little bit about the
pressure painful stimuli there are two
types that you can do to a patient to
get a response one type is called a
central stimuli and the other one is a
peripheral stimuli a central stimuli is
when pressure is applied to the center
of the body or its core to create pain
and this tests the brain's response to
that pressure slash pain so there's a
few ways you can do this one way that's
typically used first is through the
trapezius squeeze and you use your index
finger and your thumb and squeeze about
one and a half to two inches of the
trapezius muscle and as you do this you
will start out and increase the
intensity or pressure on that muscle for
up to 10 seconds and then know how the
patient responds if no response is noted
then you could move to supraorbital
pressure and this is found around the
eyes if you go to the eyebrow and go to
the inner part and you just feel with
your thumb you can feel a notch and here
you will gradually apply pressure for up
to 10 seconds to that notch and note the
patient's response now it's important to
know before you use these pressure
techniques to achieve a response in your
patient that your patient doesn't have
some type of injury so for instance if
your patient has some facial fractures
especially around the eyes you would
want to avoid using the supraorbital
pressure technique because this could
cause further damage now another type of
central stimuli that can be used is
called the sternal rub however it's
really not recommended to use this
anymore because it can cause bruising in
patients the next type is called
peripheral stimuli and this is where
pressure is applied to a peripheral
extremity for instance like the
fingernail bed and this creates pain and
this will actually help test the spinal
cord's response to pain now let's look
at the scoring for this scale so a
patient can score anywhere between a 3
to a 15. the higher the score the better
so they can't score any less than a 3
and no higher than a 15. so if a patient
gets a 15 that means that they are alert
and awake and we are really happy about
that if they score an 8 or less that
means that they are in a coma and
usually require intubation because those
airway reflexes that help protect us
aren't working too well and then if they
score a three this is the lowest score
possible there's a high rate of death
whenever a patient scores this and they
are in a very deep coma usually with a
severe head injury
now as i pointed out earlier
this tool is really good at helping us
evaluate patients with a traumatic brain
injury so we can look at those scores
and we can sort of group them with
either mild moderate or severe brain
injury so a score of 3 to 8 would mean
severe brain injury 9 to 12 would mean
moderate brain injury and 13 to 15 would
mean mild brain injury so with this
scale each of these three response
categories has their own points and we
will take those points add them up and
we get a total gcs so for eye opening
response the max amount the patient can
get is four points with a minimum of one
it's never zero you can't test it it
would be nt for not testable
verbal response the max is five again
the minimum is one there's no zero can't
test it put nt and then for motor the
max is six minimum is one so remember in
this order
evm for i verbal motor and then remember
four five six
four is the max for i five is the max
for verbal and six is the max for motor
so we add all that up and we get a total
gcs now the total gcs is important but
also these sub scores that we get from
each of the response categories is just
as important
so remember that whenever it's being
reported that you also usually see those
sub scores with it so you may see it
like gcs of seven so they have an e of
two a v of two and an m
of three now an important thing to know
before you perform this scale assessment
is to make sure that your patient
doesn't have anything that could affect
their ability to respond in any of these
three categories for instance let's say
your patient is paralyzed well that is
going to affect their motor response
or if they're intubated it's going to
limit their verbal response or if they
have any injuries to their face or any
other bones or if they have facial
swelling it's going to affect their
ability to open their eyes
along with any type of sedation or if
they're hard of hearing or have mental
deficits now the reason we want to know
this is because one we want to make sure
we're getting the best response out of
our patient for these categories but we
also want to make sure that we're
interpreting their gcs score right that
we have a good idea about what's going
on with our patient because for instance
let's say our patient is intubated well
they have a tube in their throat we're
going to have a lot of difficulty
getting a verbal response out of them so
with this we wouldn't give them a 1
because we can't test it we don't know
if they wouldn't have a response so
instead they would have nt not testable
but for eye opening for e they got a 2
and for motor m they got a 4. so they
have a gcs of 6 but that doesn't give us
the whole idea of what's going on with
them so it would look like a 6 with a t
beside of it telling the person we're
reporting this to or who's looking at
this that they're intubated so you'd
want to take it a step further and look
at those sub scores and you would look
at the e
which was a 2 you would look at the v
which doesn't tell you much but it would
have a t with it telling you if they're
intubated and then an m which would have
a four so that would help give you a
little bit of a better idea what's going
on with the patient and lets us know hey
yeah it says six but we weren't really
able to test their verbal response
because they're intubated and possibly
it might be a little bit higher but we
don't know at this time so now let's
look at this scale in depth so the first
thing what you want to assess is the eye
opening response so the e again the max
amount of points you can get is four
with a minimum of one and if you can't
test it let's say their eyes are swollen
shut or they have some crazy injuries to
their eye it'd be not testable to be nt
so the patient can get four points if
their eyes are open opening
spontaneously so let's say you walk into
the room and your patient's looking
around and their eyes are open they
would get four points
they would get three points let's say if
your patient's eyes are closed but when
you walk into the room
and they're keeping them closed but you
talk to them you introduce yourself so
you provide some verbal stimulus and
their eyes open that would be three
points but let's say walk into the room
you do that nothing happens they don't
respond to that sound
you will want to take it a little
further and you would want to apply a
pressure stimulus and that's what we
talked about the beginning of the
lecture so with this we're going to do a
peripheral stimulus
and with this what you can do is you can
take a pen a pen light whatever you have
and you're going to take it and you're
going to apply it to the nail bed of a
finger and if you do this to yourself
it's a little uncomfortable so apply
that and gradually increase pressure
over 10 seconds and see the response
their eyes open up to this they get two
points
now let's say you do all of that nothing
happens those eyes are still closed it
would be no response and they would get
a one
next is verbal response so the v with
this again you can get a max of five
points with a minimum of one and if you
can't test it let's say because they're
intubated or something like that it
would be not testable
so the patient would get five points if
they're oriented but how do we know
they're oriented well you have to ask
them a series of questions so you could
ask them to state their full name their
date of birth the month or the year or
where they're located where are they at
right now and if they answer all that
successfully they're oriented so they
get five points
they would get four points if they were
confused so if they answered any of
those questions with
something that tells you that oh they
don't really know for instance like
where they're at they're in the hospital
but they say that they're at home or the
year is 2022 but they say it's 1978 or
if they're not able to say their name
they say they're someone else they're
confused so we give them four points
three points would be whenever you ask
them questions they just start saying
words that make absolutely no sense to
those questions so we would give them
three so they're inappropriate word
usage
two points would be that they just make
sounds to those questions so no words
it's usually moaning and groaning and so
we give them two and then one point
whenever we ask them those questions you
have no response so it would be one
point and finally we have motor response
so m with this the patient can get a max
of six points with a minimum of one and
if you can't test it because let's say
they're sedated or paralyzed would be nt
for not testable so patient can get six
points if they can obey a verbal motor
command that you tell them to do so with
this it needs to be at least two steps
because we really want to make sure that
the patient's doing this and it's not
really a reflex
so
what you want to do is you can have the
patient like lift up their hands or open
their hands tell them to grasp grasp
your fingers as hard as they can and
then let go or you can have the patient
open their mouth and stick out the
tongue if they can do this all
successfully they're good to go so we
give them six points but let's say the
patient cannot do this well you got to
take it a step further and you have to
apply one of those pressure painful
stimuli that we talked about earlier and
you want to use a central stimuli so
first start out with the trapezius
squeeze if you get no response move to
the supraorbital pressure and see what
happens now the patient will get five
points if they try to localize this
pressure stimulus that you're applying
this is because that brain is trying to
locate that stimulus and it's trying to
remove it so whenever this occurs what
you're going to see is that let's say
you do the trapezius squeeze the
patient's arm is going to bend at the
elbow and move the arm and hand up above
the collarbone trying to remove that
pain now the patient will get four
points if they try to withdraw from this
pressure stimulus hence we refer to this
as normal flexion so the brain is trying
to withdraw itself from the painful
stimulus instead of trying to locate it
and remove it like before so when this
stimulus is applied through the
trapezius squeeze the patient flexes
hence bends the elbow but quickly
withdraws it from that stimulus and note
there's no rotating of the wrist the
hand and arm never make it up to that
pressure stimulus or up to that
collarbone so it doesn't locate it but
it withdraws from it now three points is
awarded if you see abnormal flexion and
we refer to this as decorticate
posturing and i want you to remember the
cor the core and decorticate because
it's key in helping you remember how
this presents so when the stimulus is
applied through the trapezius squeeze
the patient flexes the elbow gradually
and moves the arm to the center hence
the core of the body with pronation of
the forearm and flexion of the wrist and
the hands will turn into fists there
won't be the withdrawal from the
stimulus like in the previous response
and whenever you see this it's not good
it means that our cortex is affected and
then two points is awarded if you see
extension and this is known as the
cerebrate posturing and look at the word
to cerebrate look at all of those ease
there's actually four of them and that
can help you remember that this is
extension so when the stimulus is
applied with this trapezius squeeze the
patient will extend the elbow with
internal rotation of the arm and this is
actually worse posturing of all the
types and it's not a good sign it tells
us that our brain stem is affected and
then the patient will receive one point
if you applied this stimulus and there
is absolutely no response at all so now
let me test your knowledge and see if
you could calculate the gcs here our
patient is able to open their eyes
whenever pressure is applied to the nail
bed and whenever i ask some questions
they only make sounds to the questions
no words and then whenever i test the
motor response i see this
here our patient has a gcs of nine so
they have an e of two which means that
they're able to open their eyes when i
applied pressure to their nail bed they
have a v of two they only make sounds
whenever i ask them questions to see if
they're oriented or not and then they
have an m of five they were able to
localize pain whenever i applied a
trapezius squeeze okay so that wraps up
this review over the glasgow coma scale
and don't forget to access the free quiz
in the youtube description below